[Musica]
Che cos'è una coincidenza
il fatto che io sia nato lo stesso
giorno del mio compleanno è una bella
coincidenza
se uno va in stazione il treno e in
orario anche quella è una bellissima
coincidenza il fatto che noi tutti Oggi
siamo qui non è una coincidenza Ma è un
fatto semplicemente
meraviglioso
siamo qui ma potremmo non esserci
facciamoci un applauso bello forte ma
soprattutto vivo siamo vivi
Sapete che vi dico io Voglio brindare
però un brindisi che si rispetti va
fatto con il vino
Miracle
saluta
Qualcuno di voi ha pensato è una magia
qualcun altro invece ha pensato c'è il
trucco c'è il trucco qualcun altro
invece ha pensato il trucco c'è ma ci
credo opinioni diverse sulla realtà non
esistono fatti ma solo opinioni sui
fatti la realtà è un punto di vista lo
diceva anche Polifemo
ognuno di noi tutti i giorni della sua
vita si trova a vivere dei conflitti con
se stesso con l'altro con il mondo
questi conflitti non possono essere
eliminati vanno vissuti Ma come ce li
viviamo dipende da noi avere un punto di
vista magico sulla realtà può cambiare
la qualità della nostra vita ma anche
avere un punto di vista comico sulla
realtà può cambiare la qualità della
nostra vita
Chesterton un grande scrittore diceva
sapete perché gli angeli volano perché
si prendono alla leggera
un Clown dice la risata è come il
tergicristalli non fa smettere di
piovere però aiuta a vedere meglio mia
nonna abruzzese diceva sempre ogni volta
che uno ride toglie un chiodo dalla bara
bellissima
io mi emoziono quando la pronuncia
questa frase
la verità
è che la vita
continuamente ci ricorda che la magia è
dappertutto ma soprattutto ci urla con
il megafono nelle orecchie che non
bisogna prendersi troppo sul serio la
vita è il più grande mago e il più
grande comico che ci sia Ci combina
degli scherzi incredibili
sono andato in un ristorante sono
entrato Mi sono seduto mi giro vicino a
me c'era una signora bellissima con un
pancione enorme la guardo in dolce
attesa e lei no In attesa del dolce
la vita che scherzi che ci combina
qualche convivenza fa pensavo di essere
un amante eccezionale
una sera torno a casa trovo un biglietto
con su scritto scusa se ti lascio ma non
mi sento soddisfatta sessualmente
specialmente da te
era scappata con il mio migliore amico e
c'era un biglietto anche del mio
migliore amico che diceva meglio con me
che con un altro
mia nonna Me lo diceva sempre Ricordati
Domenico che ogni compagnia vanta un
cornuto se ti guardi intorno e non lo
vedi quel cornuto sei tu
la vita che scherzi che ci combina la
vita io ho un cane in Abruzzo vivo a
Bologna ma ho anche una casa in Abruzzo
un cane i miei vicini invece hanno un
pappagallo verde avevano un pappagallo
verde perché una mattina mi sono
svegliato ho visto il cane che mi veniva
incontro col pappagalli in bocca tutto
sporco di terra morto
scatta il panico cosa faccio cosa non
faccio Mi viene un'idea prendo il
pappagallo lo porto in casa lo lavo e lo
asciugo col phon che Conservo ancora
come ricordo prendo il pappagallo e lo
riporto nel giardino dei miei vicini lo
metto dentro la gabbietta
e mi metto lì a giocare col mio cane si
svegliano i vicini si avvicinano alla
gabbietta mi guardano e mi chiamano
Guardo il mio cane siamo spacciati mi
avvicino Domenico è successo una cosa
incredibile due giorni fa il pappagallo
è morto l'abbiamo sotterrato adesso
l'abbiamo ritrovato dentro la gabbietta
Lo so lo so alcuni di voi Stanno
pensando Questa è una barzelletta
ma ho sempre sognato di essere il
protagonista di questa barzelletta
tutto questo per dirvi che noi non
abbiamo accesso alla realtà lo dicono le
neuroscienze Noi abbiamo accesso a dei
modelli della realtà che sono il frutto
delle nostre convinzioni Noi siamo
marionette mosse da fili invisibili che
si chiamano con divisioni le convinzioni
determinano le percezioni e dalle
percezioni scaturiscono le nostre
opinioni
Ma le stesse convinzioni non sono vere
sono costruzioni della nostra mente sì
lo dicono le neuroscienze un famoso
neuroscienziato
in un altro Ted famosissimo ha affermato
che ogni essere vivente vive
continuamente delle allucinazioni quando
noi concordiamo con questi allucinazioni
la chiamiamo realtà
Allora mi è scattato una riflessione
come Comico eh Ci tengo a dirlo Questa è
la premessa come comico mi è scattata
questa riflessione
Forse ogni essere vivente dovrebbe avere
un bagaglio di convinzioni funzionali a
renderli una vita che lo aggrada Forse
ogni essere vivente dovrebbe avere un
bagaglio di convinzione che lo renda
felice Forse ogni essere vivente
dovrebbe avere un bagaglio di
convinzioni funzionali a raggiungere i
nostri obiettivi sì e a fare il bene
nostro ma soprattutto quello degli altri
per costruire una società più giusta più
equa ma soprattutto più umana
qualcuno di voi sta pensando Sì ma se io
non ho il bagaglio di convinzioni giuste
se io ho delle limits convinzioni
limitanti come le chiamano adesso
malefiche maleodoranti puzzolenti che
faccio vi do una buona notizia si
possono cambiare Sì è una facoltà del
Sapiens si possono cambiare Ci sono
tanti metodi io da sempre Ne utilizzo
uno
antichissimo a costo zero l'ho chiamato
metodo Roar r o r riconosci le
convinzioni che non ti permettono di
essere felice Osserva le radici sopra e
anche sotto ma non con una risata
normale no con una risata speciale la
risata come reazione a uno stimolo
comico umoristico sto parlando dello
humor Sì l'arma più potente che noi
abbiamo Come diceva il grande Mark Twain
l'arma questo tipo di arma può
trasformare qualsiasi tipo di conflitto
in risata se puoi ridere di una cosa la
puoi anche cambiare l'ha detto un grande
psicologo questo tipo di risata è
salvifica e liberatoria ci fa prendere
distanza dalle cose ci fa
disidentificare ci fa accettare il
carattere paradossale della nostra vita
sì questo tipo di risata ci aiuta a
sopportare il peso la croce la dobbiamo
portare lo stesso ma è più leggera è
come una piuma questo tipo di risata ci
fa sentire il miracolo Il mistero in cui
noi siamo immersi ogni istante della
nostra vita ma la cosa più bella di
questo tipo di risata che è una delle
risposte alla domanda delle domande che
senso ha tutto questo
la risata o ridere
aiuta a vivere e vivere aiuta a ridere
Io mi chiamo Domenico come mio Nonno
abruzzese anche lui si chiamava Domenico
all'età di 8 anni ha dovuto prendere in
mano le redini della famiglia perché suo
padre cadde dall'asino e si spezzò la
spina dorsale e era il più grande dei
Tre fratelli toccò a lui diventare il
capo famiglia ha lasciato la scuola e si
è messo a fare il contadino e il
venditore ambulante una vita piena di
sacrifici e di soddisfazioni A 69 anni è
morto di un brutto male Forse non se lo
meritava Ma la vita è un mistero
sapiente e indifferente
prima di morire Mi ha detto Domenico tu
tutte le sere ti devi addormentare con
il sorriso stampato sulla faccia se per
tanti giorni della tua vita non ti
addormenti col sorriso stampato sulla
faccia c'è qualcosa che non va nella tua
vita se puoi cambiarla se non puoi
cambiarla accoglila
[Musica]
io da qualche anno sviluppato una
convinzione Sì La vita è una grande
barzelletta E noi siamo la battuta e non
ci resta altro che ridere
un un famoso Papa diceva sempre Siamo
nelle mani del Signore Speriamo non
applauda
ma soprattutto speriamo se ne sia lavate
l'ammiraglio Nelson invece diceva Oggi
ci sei domani Ci sei dopo domani C8 ha
fondato
polvere siamo poveri ritorneremo e gli
eschimesi gradite questo lo dicevi il
grande Boris pace all'anima sua niente
permanente questo lo dice sempre il mio
parrucchiere
La nostra vita è appesa ad un filo
questo lo pensano i pesci perché loro
non parlano
ma lo pensano anche gli acrobati Sì la
nostra vita è appesa ad un filo ma lo
penso anch'io Sì la nostra vita è appesa
ad un filo e questo filo
si può spezzare si può spezzare per il
pesce nel momento in cui il filo si
spezza per il pesce il pesce che Pensa
che fortuna
si può spezzare per L'acrobata nel
momento in cui il filo si spezza per
L'acrobata L'acrobata che pensa che
sfortuna stessa realtà due punti di
vista diversi Infatti dentro la parola
sfortuna c'è la parola fortuna Ma si può
spezzare anche per me nel momento in cui
il filo si spezza per me invece penso
che la realtà è un punto di vista e
forse il filo che sembra spezzato in
realtà non lo è
Perché Perché esiste la magia
non lo sapevate Esiste la magia La magia
e negli occhi di chi guarda se tu ci
credi alla magia La magia può accadere
se tu non ci credi alla magia La magia
non può accadere
potremmo anche dire il trucco c'è ma ci
credo
la provata si salva il pesce finisce in
padella e L'acrobata se lo mangia e la
vita continua
sono uscito con la mia compagna una
puzza incredibile Amore che cos'è questa
puzza il profumo Dolce e Gabbana l'ho
appena comprato devi guardare dentro la
boccetta perché forse dolce o Gabbana è
morto
per te un profumo per me è una puzza
due punti di vista diversi lo diceva
anche il poeta l'erba per il cavallo c'è
un profumo per gli innamorati c'è un
altro profumo perché la verità è che
ognuno di noi ha il naso che si merita
cioè il naso quello lungo
quello di Pinocchio c'è il naso alla
francese quello quello proprio a forma
di Torre Eiffel c'è il naso alla greca
quello che di profilo è un profilattico
all'inglese quello quello senza bidet
all'insulina sarà su per giù quello
preferito da Pablo Picasso e poi c'è il
naso più bello del mondo
quello per sentire il profumo delle
vostre risate e dei vostri applausi
saluta